science magazine presents a special
issue each year on the scientific
breakthrough of the year in 2009 it's
our top Ithaca ramidus the most detailed
look at early hominid life this is
indeed a major breakthrough because this
is something that even as scientists we
never expected so we're sharing this new
data to the to the general public and it
couldn't be more interesting than you
know than this in October
science magazine held a press conference
with four of the forty-seven authors who
together published 11 papers in the
October 2nd issue of science it is one
of the most revealing hominid fossils I
could ever have imagined much less had
the privilege of studying if you were to
ask someone on the street today
what did an early ancestor of humans
look like they would probably say well
it would look like Lucy and before that
it would look like a chimpanzee what the
fossils that are being described in
science today will tell you is that both
of those conclusions are very incorrect
so instead of thinking of something in
between a chimp and a human we have to
think of this as really not a series of
links in a chain as much as branches in
a tree and our branch is a very peculiar
branch we have very strange feet and
huge brains how did that happen
well we have to work our way back down
our branch and so we're getting pretty
close to the fork that was between the
line that led off to the chimpanzees and
the line that led off to us and
ardipithecus takes us pretty far back
toward that branch and informs us that
the node point the junction the last
common ancestor was neither human nor a
chimpanzee it was something entirely
different it's living on the ground
walking upright like us spending a lot
of time walking upright if you saw it
walk by the walk would look a lot like
ours but it can't run
I guess the skeleton we have is
estimated to be around four feet tall
and to weigh around a hundred hundred
and ten pounds and so that's why
skeletons are important they allow you
to get at things like stature limb
proportions and and all of that and I
think one of the one of the things that
we would be most impressed by seeing
seeing Ardipithecus in in the flesh
would be the very small size of her face
and brain brain case the very large size
of her arms and hands and this grasping
ability of her feet she had a foot with
an opposable large toes first time we've
ever seen this in a fossil hominid all
the rest of them even the Lucy species
fairly early at 3.7 23.2 and even with
footprints in the footprints that the
large toe is right in line with the
other toes there's already an arch to
the foot Arty's foot was not like that
when Artie walked it towed off of the
lateral four digits and the large toe
was off to the side acting more in
stabilization instead of in toe off and
so it's a very different creature what
that does what the maintenance of that
grasping foot does for you is to open up
the arboreal environment so during the
dramatists time certainly the area was
kind of area with major streams flowing
from the highlands this was already a
basin valley and so there were major
streams riverine forests and canopy
forests wait we can say this because we
see a lot of segments that are the
segment's that were brought by these
rivers apart from the different animals
that existed there so geologically
weakened seas the environment was very
conducive for those animals to live in
that's how science proceeds we make
hypotheses we test them with
and sometimes they fail and the
hypothesis that the earliest bipeds
evolved in a Savannah habitat has now
failed in the face of this new evidence
well Ardipithecus ramidus hands and
forearms weren't as stiff as a modern
chimpanzee or gorillas if your knuckle
walking going like this you need to have
a very stiff wrist and you need to have
fingers that can handle that weight and
all the forces there's all sorts of
adaptations that autopathy cos did not
have it had a much more flexible hand
and wrist so it was able to free up the
hands to do other things so it turns out
that that last common ancestor was
probably not a knuckle Walker at all
knuckle walking evolved independently in
gorillas and in chimps more primitive
morphological characters and systems
have been retained and as a consequence
even the human hand today is probably
more primitive than the chimpanzee hand
is today and that's really one of the
biggest lessons of Ardipithecus is that
we can't just take a modern animal like
a chimp or gorilla and use it as a proxy
for the last common ancestor chimps and
gorillas have been evolving for 6 & 7
million years - and so what we're seeing
here is something that we never could
have predicted from either a modern
human or a modern chimpanzee the only
way to learn about this creature is
through the paleontological record if we
were a couple of chimps sitting here
talking about our ancestor we'd have
very little to say because there's
almost no fossil record of of
chimpanzees and was not in fact until a
few years ago we now have a handful of
teeth from about 500,000 which are very
interesting but they don't tell us a
whole lot about the whole evolution of
chimpanzees there are no fossil gorillas
either and so if we knew these lineages
we'd know a lot more about ourselves as
well and partly because of this it's
been assumed that the last common
ancestor of humans and chimps
with rather chimp-like and it's it you
can't deny it because you have no
evidence that chimps were any different
then than they are now the significance
of this is that it's earlier in time
nearer the last common ancestor and if
we want to know what the less common
ancestor was and to try and understand
the forces that led to our divergence
from a chimpanzee ancestor this is much
more relevant we began to work in the
middle of Washington 1981 we really
didn't know what was going to be found
this is long term protracted scientific
research endeavor and this kind of work
does actually take decades it doesn't
take that long if you don't find
anything but we've found a great deal
we've found something like 15 separate
horizons in this kilometre of rock that
have yielded hominid fossils we have
over 18,000 vertebrate fossils thousands
of artifacts from multiple horizons
Ardipithecus is one snapshot within that
depository but it's the best snapshot
and it's the most detailed snapshot it
is the most data rich snapshot there are
so few skeletons of fossil humans that I
don't know four or five and you can tell
so much more when you've got a whole
skeleton that when you've got a few bits
and pieces even if you've got bits of
different parts of the skeleton knowing
that they're all associated in wanted
individual is really exciting the
interpretations that go along with it
are very provoking some of them are
undoubtedly true I'm sure others will be
topics of discussion for a good while
but the basic data I think is what
really counts here and the fact that
you've got a fairly complete skeleton
you've got a lot of other associated
things is what at this particular time
there is what's really significant about
this specimen we may have thought that
human evolution began somewhat by
accident a million years ago with the
discovery of tools or two-and-a-half
million years ago with the discovery of
the first stone tools
but in fact our deepika cos tells us
that we as humans have been evolving
toward what we are today for at least 6
million years
the name Ardipithecus ramidus is based
on an off our name for ground RT and
remedy for root and so if you want to
think of it that way it's kind of like
the root of the ground Apes we in the
middle I wash project try to respect the
local culture by naming when we can
the scientific name based on and off our
root science is published by triple-a is
the science Society